welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
at long last I've pinned down ed Stier
who is the co-founder of sphere digital
recruitment they are a specialist
digital recruitment company that work
with technology vendors agencies and
brands across the UK Europe and North
America they're headquartered in the UK
and have offices in London and
Manchester have circa 65 staff and have
been going for just under 8 years
Ed's thank you for joining me at long
last hi thank you for patience so as
we've the same we're we're I always
always love to start on this podcast is
yeah how did Ed steer and to the lovely
world of recruitment let's start there
yes or I graduated back in 2005 went to
Oxford Brookes and did did media and new
media new media yeah yeah yeah I wanted
to go in something like PR quite like
writing and I just felt like 18 years
old PR PR looked like a cool job but
then what I realized was it didn't pay
very much and I'm really greedy so I had
a gap year before Union I worked in a
telly sales job I worked in phone shops
all the way through uni and I know I
really wanted to come to London and do a
sales job that was my kind of main
premise so I rang a company called the
graduate recruitment company and they
placed grads into media sales I didn't
know what media sales walls but I had a
media degree so I rang rang around the
Aussie rang the GRC and a lady answered
the phone who was then known as Nicola
Jenkins now Nicola the boom and she
invited him into the graduate
recruitment company and I had a few
inches with their clients but they ended
up interviewing me themselves and I
joined I ended up plumping to join to
join the GRC so ok that's why I got into
recruitment and Jenko as I don't know
her now works at sphere so good Wow
really oh yeah all around story and the
person the person I sat next to you when
I joined the GRC was God could
annihilate yeah whose part the founding
team
Wow a sphere and go one step further
my now wife their oh my god Kerry and
spheres non exec director is a guy
called Lawrence and that's Kerry's dad
because the person went on to marry had
that had built and sold a recruitment
company called Harrison Willis we got to
about 250 staff Lee sold it in late 90s
Wow and then he sold it he went on to
buy a zoo so like an actual zoo in theme
park where he would then become the
Tiger King today he's not the talking no
okay well yes yes he was great we form
some good bonds but I actually had one
on recruitment I had a cup of nation and
go to uni and one of them by the time I
graduated you know when I went when I he
didn't go too sick for me that he went
with an estate agency then he started
working recruitment and by the time I
graduate with my first sheet will drive
up in a BMW and buy my final year he was
driving up in a Porsche and something he
and I sort of thought what do you do and
he set up a recruitment of the places
local doctors and they did that on yeah
very very very well they were very big
company and based on Milton Keynes so I
had one eye on recruitment I have a lot
of my mates from school who actually
kind of had gone into it straight
straight from school there's you know I
grew up in in in Bedfordshire kind of
between Milton Keynes and Bedford okay
and so I hadn't met most my mates lived
in Milton Keynes I was in a village just
outside of there a lot of my friends
have gone into recruitment straight
straight from school and so I always
always had one iron it suggests a
framework so obviously with you and
running and building your own
recruitment business obviously mentioned
there now your business partner yeah
definitely gonna focus on that today
yeah definitely talk about what you've
been going for over the last couple of
weeks but let's really focus on the
sphere journey right but just to sort of
let just a framework for everyone so
from what I saw online you worked at
that company you met was it so that
company what was that the FIR
did you where there's lot free and a bit
years and then starts there it was a bit
long there so I'll give you the verb
with a very quick version so I joined I
joined the GRC I placed grads into a
state agency in my first ten months I
was a third top bidder in but only ten
months in the business
that year yeah I'm so I've really hit
the ground running it was a quick desk
to get up and running on had the Foxtons
account and back in the dark if you've
spoken to me he said my fingers I didn't
go to uni mates they were very okay
they're okay but and so I placed grads
into a state agency I went on to run to
right to run a team within the GRC and
then in 2008 there was a recession and
at that point the the Aspire who is now
which the GRC was part of this will be
branded as a spy now and they let quite
a few managers go and I was given just a
mishmash of teams everything that didn't
have a manager was given to me I was
good at you know hugging people and
keeping people and developing pillars
and that was a great great experience
because I learned to run different teams
my market died so I actually ended up
doing Directorate for a year one of the
teams I was given with it was yeah one
of the teams I was given was a failing
wreck to wreck team and because my job
market because my market died I just
sort of thought I need a market and the
rectorate guys were saying was hard my
thought well can't be that hard
so the year of rhetoric but
simultaneously I'd make Kerry my now
wife yeah and I'd been speaking to her
dad and I've kind of said I want to set
up a company and he'd really encouraged
me to set up a company so said that you
know you can do it and you know you
should
so from kind of three or four years into
my career I knew I want to set up a
business I knew that what I was running
didn't make any sense in terms of no it
wasn't very scalable or replicable so I
then moved internally and I took on the
digital team so I spent four years up
until the end of the recession yeah
running grads and then running this real
mishmash of teams and then I had about
three years running the digital team but
juju during that three-year period
Laurence and I had already really got
into the planning of sphere and we were
very deep in you know what it's gonna be
how they operate the financing of it so
yes so and I was a real saver I didn't
spend very much money I'd bought
unfortunate after Best Buy flank lap and
rinsed out spare room and then my wife
and I moved down to Brighton so that she
could work at the zoo the family
business and
kept letting out my fat in London and
then the plan was always sell the flat
that's gonna be my startup money and we
man escaped a bank a bank loan - so yes
a lot I've been panic stiff a long time
and then I always wanted to go into
business with someone so bad was that I
just think that I didn't want to be me
on my own in an office okay
and I think that we know we're better
together and I'd known a long time he
had been working together but we were
amazing friends and you know a Frenchie
gone gone on and on and on since since
launching sphere and I thought would be
a good team so yeah
Laurence and I went went to work on
getting him to to sign up and come and
be part of it and then now obviously was
no absolutely ecstatic and over the moon
and excited so for the last year the
planning it was done is that done as a
done as a trio but we launched with a
really good a really good plan and a
really clear idea of where we were going
let's talk about that so I think so it
seems very probably the yeah seems very
calculative right yeah that's the right
word strategic so let's just talk about
this I think so from speaking to a lot
of recruiters typically a lot of people
are worried about that first year right
yeah they're worried about not being
able to pay the bills they're worried
about are they gonna be able to get
clients just all the normal things that
come with the things that could all the
normal things that could stop someone
standing on recruitment business so so
the first thing so how did you come up
with the name that was the hardest thing
I've done since launching spear we just
went through every name under the Sun
and we everything that was cool like we
had fuse like fuse talent I mean there's
a few others poison samurai core nap
that did to us nine years ago or eight
years go be every single cool name has
been taken by another recruitment
company some sort of agency of some sort
of serve even our IT so that's every
call every cool word was was gone
so we start looking at word thesauruses
and one of the words we put in was
knowledge we were putting in know every
every cliche Under the Sun anyway one of
the words was was sphere that came from
knowledge and then Niall looks it said
that looks like steer and feelin which
are our names so we went for we went for
sphere but spell
SPH EE us when we listed the company
company's house it was sphere spell s
phwr my surname s T W R and then we
realized actually that was a hard word
to say and comforting with a hard word
to spell we realize it was very bad idea
so we went Mystere the normal word and
then digital recruitment I'm a huge
believer in simplicity and when I was
looking at company websites to get
website inspiration so many companies
didn't say what they did and it was yeah
and it really frustrated me and land on
a website and that's been the first two
minutes funny I know what the hell does
this company do yeah and that was not to
recruitment that was across a lot of
industries so we wanted to be very
simple and say what we did digital
recruitment ok no say what you do on the
tin and also from a search point of view
we ranked really well on Google from the
get-go because how digital did swear
hand and our URL URL with sphere London
so people search digital jobs London
just to recruitment London so we went to
come on no we became we were ranking
pretty quickly so you said that you you
had a really good plan right so let's
talk about this so so firstly you hear
all the time I want to start my own
recruitment business when I dip my
Wanger do it different like how did you
plan to differentiate yourself in what
is an extremely saturated market so so
I'm not a big believer it's might be
contra not its conversion but I don't I
don't think that it's about difference I
think there's some fundamentally things
that make basic basic business is
brilliant and that's all about the way
that you do the way that you run the
company so that's about how you onboard
people how you train people how you
specialize in markets how you use your
CRM but they're the basics that are the
backbone to any any business working
brilliantly yeah so one thing I would
work would says before you set up a
company I think you need to have a bit
of a heart-to-heart yourself and decide
what what do you want to be there's no
there's no right or wrong answer to that
question but no I always wanted to you
know set up and grow you know a business
that became a big one and a global
business so we yeah we would never set
out to be a lifestyle business we were
always we were always set up to grow and
it was always going to be about
you know nurturing developing nurturing
and developing people and talent you
know I I love being with people and
working with people and helping cheap
people achieve amazing results but
that's inside our business and when I
recruited I you know I I loved working
with my customers and our customers and
and and but it was no people finding
jobs with businesses hiring I really
enjoyed that sense of nurturing people
and getting results so we were really
set up to scale and and well let's talk
about that for a sec then what what were
the key parts of your plan that enabled
the men that yourself to scale good
funding so you need to be willing to
invest and was and was it so part just
but let's be clear on that so you had to
have money from that flat yes well I put
in money
Lauren spent some money non-live been
both took salary sacrifices we didn't
draw a salary for the first six months
we don't we were actually both were in a
financial position where we could not
draw a salary for up to a year if needs
be obviously no living living living
living not the way we were used to but
that was tons okay and then we managed
to get an overdraft from a bank which is
really unheard of for a recruitment
company but we had an amazing plan and
Lauren snide been speaking to banks for
a long time so okay we put in a hundred
and ten K in cash we got an overdraft
150 200 60 grand and those salaries and
but we were making fees from from from
we three today yes we could good funding
and then that'll be a really good plan
so we sort said no what jobs are we
gonna feel what clients are we gonna
work with yeah so you know very good
kind of just basic plan around jobs and
jobs will fill and candidates will place
and then actually it was it was
replication I didn't believe in
differentiating ourselves beyond know
being the very best at what we do that's
going about in a recruitment business
that's all about the people you can
attract and the way that you look after
them thereafter from a personal
development point of view yeah sure so
so yeah we had you know we had a career
development plan in place before we
launched we had induction training
written before we launched so I've been
doing these things for a long for a long
time okay before startup so so we had a
lot of these things in place and then we
had a really good business plan for the
first three years and
actually the first few years we're
really just going and replicating what
we were used to so it was replicating
the teams that would run previously an
hour old in our old job so a lot of that
was just done just just just just a case
of no replication more than them William
when did you make your first hire day 19
2010 then really go for spear sorry yeah
therefore man yeah why'd you think he
was able to do it so quickly if in your
career you nurture relationships and you
do the best form business Furman is
doing a good job if you do a good job
they you know have covenants I did but
and they were they were absolutely water
types of what I did on day one was I
rang around people who are new and I
just said I've said to become pannu
please can you send me every every job
you'll be briefed on by recruiters and
if it wasn't if it wasn't a restricted
company then it-- then I chased the job
and I spoke to people who who I knew who
are dealt with but who might who I
wasn't restricted from because we hadn't
placed with them and so I had a long
list of restrictions but I'd identified
who worked out who was not covered by
those covenants and then yeah just good
off good old-fashioned biddies I know I
would just talk about relationships know
if you've got if you the best form of
business development is doing a good job
it always amazes me how recruiters will
like Magpies I want to work the next new
company in the next new company and
they'll work on a job for you know a bit
of time and either fill it or not but
that we don't go back to the same so
throughout my recruitment career anybody
I ever spoke to I always wanted to keep
speaking to them and I really ran teams
about it was kinda like if someone's if
someone's given us a job we will keep in
touch with them forever even if they
don't work so so just that kind of a set
of basic basic ways of working so yeah
so it was a yes were able to pick up
business through nurturing a network and
managing those relationships and I think
just just just just having a you know a
good reputation and then and then it's
about delivery once we got one sitting
on the job once we got on when they said
when did you make your first verse hi
yes or he was a guy called Ali and he
joined us on the 11th of March so we're
an October November December January
February she had five months before he
joined but we'd found him in jail
Yui and then and then the next higher
after that was in April that was an
administrator l couldn't Iommi and then
we hired a guy called Joe and Joe Joe
was recommended to me by someone on my
old someone on my old team aspired got
internal I said who's your favorite
recruiter she said this guy called Joe
so he got got stuck into Joe and he he
came on board and then someone called
Gemma who used to work for me at a spire
she was kind of ways in the business
plan she came in launched another team
for us which market we wanted to be
supposed that was a market launch and a
strategic one and then y'all can go
through the names but I'm in founding
how many people did you end up nine by
nine by the end of the first year okay
so let's just talk about this for a sec
so okay so firstly this comes up a lot
from people who misses me yeah when
you're a small business like that
clearly you've fought about this a long
time and you obviously you're someone
that backs yourself and yeah the reason
why I'm saying this is because a lot of
people in there that sort of smaller
size yeah a lot of people stay around
those sort of numbers right wish you all
see haven't in terms of headcount the
end why when tashu is like why did they
join you like what what was the like how
did you get these people to join you to
sitting in them whatever it was he was
yeah I get them to be like what was that
what was the cell and how did you get
people fall into the narrative vision
and then being able to back it up so I'm
in Oregon called Matt who now runs one
of our technology sales teams and he bet
me anything that my wife said I can't do
another star stocks I've joined a few
and it's not gone to plan yeah so I said
what what what are your concerns about
startup you said things like no have you
got the jobs depth of relationship for
candidates ongoing plans so I just said
to him I he actually worked in a
competing business I said that I'm not
look not not looking to steal your job
to tell me one the jobs you're hiring
for so you sold me a job and I went on
the database and I pulled up five
candidates and said there's a shortlist
or that job and then I pulled up our
revenue trackers and I showed him every
time we were working with and then I
showed him our career development plan
so it's just about know that the story
around me and me and me and nan and
Lawrence and having Lawrence's
involvement was really important in the
video so he had that sort backing and
then it was just um you know just it was
just vision and I think people really
not everyone but people
really trusted that we were going
somewhere and we had loads and we still
do had loads of passion and loads of
excitement for the business and the
thing is that success is a sort of
self-perpetuating wheel and what I
underestimated actually was how how how
easy it was to hire people in the
beginning over the first few years
because we could really sell them into
the story actually hiring became harder
when we got to about 40 or 50 people
because the differentiators became a bit
more different so you know the narrative
is is it different but we've always been
really big on vision really big on
actually communicates and telling people
where we're going and make them part
part of that journey the difference is
is you've grown you've actually think or
track record to fall back on so you can
just say look here's the people his
achievements in the dream and then and
then and then in time you're selling the
track record and yeah alright and and
the dream yeah so but I think so if
you're a small company and you want to
grow you need to get built to grow so we
never yeah okay we never like grew and
then for all we grown what do we need to
do now we thought about it what do we do
what it needs to do to grow and then we
did you something hey yeah you had the
mentality of like what you were acting
before you you're doing what you you're
doing the stuff that you will be doing
when you get there sort of thing but
you're doing today rather than wait
until yeah you decide you've got decide
the destination and then when you know
the destination is you work back from
eiko that's the destination how do we
get there what are the steps and then
you and then and then and then you and
then you and then you get to work on the
on the step ok cool no cuz that was only
my next question was like what's the
message then to smaller businesses that
through fight because that's the thing
it's like there will be the majority
market is sub 10 staff like how and
their biggest challenges if it will be
if they do on a scale will grow is
hiring people right yeah yeah what what
you've wise young people join them and
it's so competitive yeah absolutely yeah
totally I think I think that the owners
and the key people in those companies
need to decide first of all why why are
they growing and what do they want to
achieve because if you're growing a
business although it's really cool that
the sack
Feist is a massive because you've got to
you've got to put people before you put
yourself in terms of your own your own
needs so I think what what a small
coming sometimes struggle with is they
want to hire people so they hire them
but they're worried about fees dropping
so the owners kind of focus on fees and
they don't focus on the people in the
business so you've got to be really
willing if you're gonna grow to to
absolutely give everything to the people
who join your business and the only way
you can really do that is um it's by
working seven days a week for 14 15
hours a day that's it now that's how we
were able to indulge people train people
on board people and and yeah and keep
the revenue up and then you've got to be
good at letting go of things so now we
very quickly started building our
management team and it would very young
people with not much experience but we
know we invest in training we pay rate
to rec fees we know we had really clear
plans around our career development know
a lot of that was taken from oil
companies be honest but yeah we we made
sure that even though were a small
company know people have performance
reviews every three months and we we I
think if you haven't got a thing they're
closing some place miss isn't it because
they think I don't need that yet I'll do
that yeah so okay so I had an amazing
experience I won't say where it's not
willing to him but I had six weeks in
another company between a spy so when I
when I was new was gonna set up a
business I went and joined a an another
company I know you sailor for six weeks
and I went back to expire spine took the
job well for me which was the head of
digital job but it was amazing six weeks
and basic as a company who they said
though ten people and I joined they were
six and they've been going about ten
years and I was offered a job you know
equity come and grow
yeah full Spanish telegram paper and it
was one of the best things ever happen
to me because they didn't have anything
in place to grow no people on different
Commission structures there was no
transparency yeah it looked great from
the outside because they could say oh no
we're young and always small and with
flexible me a boutique but I said to the
owner the reason you're not gonna ever
grow this company is because there's no
plan to do it there's no there's nobody
there's no plan to grow and he said oh
we'll put that in place when we grow and
I said but but you're not going to grow
because you haven't got the player so
but I think what you get in companies
you haven't got the
infrastructure is you tend to they tend
to just churn through people little bit
and yeah but that's not a bad that's not
a bad thing at all it's just for me it's
just about deciding you know what what
do you want to be so you can kind of
make your decisions around around that
okay
so let's wrap this first year up then
how proof the were you in the first year
we may 220k from turnover of 800 really
yeah so and we were mistake lots of cash
all purpose okay right okay so let's
just for a sec let's think about so it
all sounds great right
what was what happened in that first
year that you didn't plan for and that's
a very good question
we ended up launching things we didn't
plan for so you have to be what we've
always won a gold ballad as adaptability
so this guy Joe who joined who was
amazing and went on to be brilliant we
hired him into a market to do one sort
of technology sales with me which didn't
retake too so you know took him pretty
much six months to make his first fee
but actually during that process he said
look I'm interested in another type of
tech can I run with it and we said
absolutely please do and then the next
year he was our top biller anyone input
to Ana for ground on the year and and
and and and and and that was amazing
actually sad took us into another aside
from Ruby technology so we followed yeah
we followed people often you have to
follow people in recruitment so small
things but like um yeah one team we had
which I was running people were gonna
place two types of Rob jobs one with
sales and one was account management but
Ali who he hired didn't like doing sales
highs he liked doing account managers
and this guy met who joined whose runs
our technology sales team now he liked
doing sales so I very quickly split
those teams into and then and then Joe
who John that team ended up doing a
third team but so we sort of followed
those three people but actually the
beginning of year two i sat down with
those guys and said oh we want to grow
three teams around each you know you
ended up being quite niche but we're
gonna work with you I'm gonna work with
you so that by the end of this year you
will all be running a division each and
so yes we thought we definitely followed
people so I think when you've got a
destination short know where you're
going but
know exactly how you'll get this I think
you follow you follow people and take
take their leaders take Bibi be willing
to take their leaving it okay so let's
just think about that the next two years
and so let's break this down so you said
they're around at the real solid
business plan for the first three years
yeah and then we'll talk about the sort
of last three years right so yeah the
end of sort of the third year yeah there
was you out as a business let's say we
yes yep so we've got we'd got up to a
year three so turnover NIAMS 800k
turnover in year two is 1.6 million
turnover in year three was 2.4 million
that's net net for he so it followed a
pretty good revenue go gross yeah that's
not revenue that's net income net fee
income yet we didn't do much contract in
fact we didn't do any contracts that at
all yeah it's all perm yep what about
head count was 25 okay
somewhere between 25 to 30 I wouldn't
know the exact number but what happened
that would also hard an FDA other
functions that come in so we had like
someone in the marketing function where
how soon did you invest in that Niomi
who joined us as our second high was my
admin and social media and then she
became classic yeah became then she
became admin social media and credit
control they hired someone could
Charlotte who became admin and gnomes
gnomes became credit control and
marketing and then and then Shotokan
credit control and loans was just
marketing and then we hired an FD who's
been absolutely game-changing a guy
called Ben who's also my younger brother
really yeah yeah it's been amazing he's
an when did you hire him so that was in
year 3 and he's an economics grad from
bond of year 3 or halfway through he
joined on June the 6th of 2015 and that
was gained we knew we needed a finance
manager and yeah we just didn't see
anyone we loved and Lawrence actually
said like what about what about your
brother
and I didn't want to [ __ ] up his career
cuz I was very proud of what he did he
know studied hard and had an amazing
career in and he worked to tighten line
in their in their strategy departments
yeah boy that but her so I I just said
to Ben that this is completely different
but it could be amazing and it helped a
lot from before launch we've done a lot
of our financial modeling for like how
we track KPI
how we track register payment voucher z'
and love and in anyway so he was at he
was actually 11 weeks into a notice
period to join Eurostar in a in in a
senior finance role we're in their
strategy Department again and and yet we
you know we met and he said yeah I'll
give it a whirl if it goes badly he had
all his no actual qualifications to fall
back on
so he joined then and he took on finance
and that's just been game-changing for
us because the role that Ben plays in
running and steering the businesses and
is phenomenal and the dynamic that
bought to me and Niall and Lawrence it
was really great to have someone else on
the board at that point as well just
yeah a whole new dynamic and yeah Ben
Ben's just learned so much we've gone
from so spent that was key and then and
then you see Ilya three I was in more of
a natural managing director job with
Bill good management team I was nodding
and I was running our e-commerce team
and was top biller so you know he was
really still banging him fees which
amazing to have that balance and feeling
leadership so on and that was always the
plan we always kind of joined we were
set up with slightly different slightly
different roles yeah in in in mind for
the business and yeah and then Ben Ben
was not ft at that point we came in he
claimed his Financial Controller we
price him to ft after about after about
12 months although he's on the board
from day one but yes so end of end of
end of year three we've got to kind of
like we had the key teams in place and
key non-fee earning functions in place
in the back office and I know JJ who
spoke to mention mentioned something
called a five-year strategy we actually
said there's a poster the board just
producing a strategy we then went this
amazing experience in the second half of
the third year where we broke the
company up in six teams he looked at
different parts of the business and then
they everyone was involved every single
member of the business and they went
away and looked at these different parts
of sphere and said in five years time
what should we do so it seems like
growth personal development no clean air
so so so so let's ride on them by them
but like that's okay well so would let's
definitely so one free that is like
going into your free to where you are
now
right because clearly that's the case so
the reason why I wanna brush over and
why I but I didn't is because like I'm
sure you have all these conversations
all the time
your part on networking events and stuff
like that and you will yet people will
be looking people 170 living it's finger
how the [ __ ] they got to that point
right yeah because the most common
message I get from business owners
particularly is I can't get past his 15
head monk I can't get past his 10 head
mark whatever so I don't just brush over
the fact that you went from a really
slick clearly watertight business plan
the executed you ended up having quite a
few people in your business by in the
year one your profitable and you
increased profitability whilst also
increase in the headcount in year free
right because I think for me talking
about the present day the conversations
I'm having I feel like that when we
start coming back out of this the
businesses that got caught in the sort
of vanity of headcount and rather than
the actual bottom-line cash flow
probably hand a bit of reality check
right now so I don't know sort of brush
over those sort of first copies because
I feel like little bit so like I just
want to sort of dig into like how how
did you sustainably grow the business
for those three years like in terms of
money-wise but also get people in like
how war messages to enable you to do
that
good good performance and good retention
so if you if you don't retain people
it's it's extreme how much did you
invest how much did you what was a
comparison in terms of investing getting
new people and retaining people I mean I
wouldn't know the exact numbers but very
low churn particularly particularly in
those years I mean why do you think that
is
I think if someone's in a company they
love in a job they love and if you're
moving forwards then then then then you
tend to stick with it so yeah that's
fear every year people can look back on
the previous year and so I think they've
had tangible career growth and I think
that's that's that that's what we really
worked how did you measure that with
your how did you get your consultants to
see that without it just being there
Billings
so we have something called progress so
that you as a recruiter which includes
your billing is the role you play in
your team and your personal development
so and then we have a grading system so
our lowest grades you can get pay rises
every three months every quarter okay
and then and then once we get to see any
consultant every six months and when so
we that was all just yeah that was all
tracked and we know we really we really
invested him in people and progress
overs that everyone always has a
pay-rise target
place everyone always knows exactly when
the next review is gonna be and what did
you measure that on circles I think
that's really interesting so what did
you what did you measure the Rema
criteria which was revenue okay yeah
Billings yeah
roll within your team so that how you
how you operate in your team Locksley
the more scene you get the expectations
change and personal development and
that's all about becoming autonomous and
you know taking control of your own
taking control of your own how do you
measure that
really basic so it's like when someone's
brand new we don't expect them to
prepare for one two ones but we expect
their manager but once but once
someone's good with for three months we
say right we really want you here to
prepare for your own one two ones and
prepare for your own day okay and we're
here to guide you and when someone's
kind of like been with us for a year we
wouldn't expect them to come in and map
out their whole next 12 months and say
I'm gonna make this much money from
these clients you know these my but but
but we'd say to them right now now in a
year's time we want for you to be able
to completely map out next year
everything Australia now for your there
yeah Abbott say yeah have a strategy
swim we you know you can't ask people to
make more money you got it starts with
competence and behavior so we really
focus not on the on the money but on the
competencies and the behaviors okay
people people find that hard because
you're asking people to actually look at
themselves and and and and and and and
and and look at what they need to tune
up and help what what their key
qualities are and how they can get get
get get better with those but yeah
progress creates a lot of fairness
across the business and it creates a lot
of transparency but also creates no
absolutely amazing focus on where you
are and where you're going
so that's true and and it's supported
through and it's supported through lots
of training but but the real answer is
amazing management where you've got
brilliant management that just create
layer and believe you know that's so
important and then hiring well that's
pretty basic thing I remember yeah yeah
baby ever not a mineral cream abyss to
do that we don't get me wrong we've
we've we've had bad years and went and
when it from hiring point of view and
and sometimes that's on us and sometimes
it's on making bad hires and it's you
know it's a combination of the two I
guess but yeah what I think that we
didn't find we didn't find obviou we
didn't find
going to 25 people challenging they were
obviously tough bit so I was thinking
wrong it was it was up and down you know
it's recruitment it's the roller
coasters you described knows up and down
and know I've always been I couldn't
remember what I was stressing about but
we would have been stressing about
something a lot in the ERDs but we I
think where we found it harder was that
transition from 30 to 50 people because
you can what happens in that point is I
think you grow the heads because you've
probably got the money in the appetite
to do it but you haven't really got the
experience and that's both the board and
and and and with quite a junior
management team so yeah we I think that
companies find that I get it once you
get to 25 which is difficult but kicking
on again I think is even harder okay so
just just a quick one before we go it
really keen to go into sort of how
involved your people were in the
five-year strategy and stuff like that
because this is what you're coming
towards now in the present yes and just
a quick one on the I guess two things
actually it's coming to mind so in terms
of like the actual higher MP so in those
first three years did you get better at
understanding what good hiring triggers
were no would you wait because you
clearly on the believe we're out like
what was the week we got better as we
got more mature about the when we were
small small if someone you know one is
to do something their life and and and
and and met the culture I joke I think
actually I've always play salespeople so
I think we were pretty good collectively
getting to the heart of you know what
makes a good salesperson okay we also
were pretty robust on we had it we had a
we had a high bar so we always had a
higher high bar although naturally
people slip through the net it's more
about where where we hired badly was
just through to things and our appetite
for growth and then this real confidence
that we could really take people and
shape them and nurture them so we don't
think are we've seen something that
person we can really we can really mold
them but and actually when we were
smaller we probably could because the
reality was I got a lot more time with
people what would you tell than everyone
yeah yeah and I obviously but as we got
bigger when we were doing there and
you're managing through junior managers
it's actually unfair on a junior manager
to ask them to train someone may or may
not be great so what we really learned
was we needed to stop thinking we could
make people who were okay amazing yeah
and we needed to we needed to let the
new let them manage let managers develop
develop their skills and I had four or
five years management experience before
launching sphere and and and I'd made
I've learned a lot and and we were
asking sometimes junior managers to go
and hire too many people too quickly in
there and and that and that's that's
definitely a recipe for disaster so yeah
when we learn we learn about that but we
also though we've grown a lot it's never
felt crazy we've never we now have
graduate intakes where we might hire
like five or six people together yeah
twice a year but but outside of that our
gross has been very it's been it's been
very very quick but it's actually been
built around there being steady you know
ten ten to fifteen people year ten
people year fifteen people years has
been I've been quite a nothing keep
thing as you said is keeping those ten
or fifteen people after you clearly you
haven't been like a a leaking bucket no
and so I think that's the really key
thing and I think it's great that you've
really sort of highlighted that and
spoken a lot about career progression
and because that was one of the things
that I think I've noticed having worked
one reeking silence but then looking at
sphere as a whole when you look at your
concerns on LinkedIn there's quite a few
people that have worked for you for
three years four years five years plus
yeah and that's clearly evident on the
may that means clearly then a big part
that is because these people each year
how little bigger is they know what a
good a better year looks like yeah yeah
we talked a lot about growth no we we
were start up every day and we've got
we've got so many things that we will
achieve in the future but the only way
we'll do that is by people stepping into
jobs you know we're always all know
we're always if ever your life if if
someone's always stepping up into a new
job then that creates space behind them
for someone else to step up into that
job and when we do launch new areas
where we can we would always do
things in internally so absolute
preference so yeah we're but I think and
I hope that our team realized that
there's really amazing opportunities for
for future growth and roles to step into
because for us to achieve what we want
to is so much about it's about us doing
it together it's about people in the
business taking those opportunities but
we've also learned that that needs to be
done with patience you know you know
putting someone in the job they're not
quite ready to do is actually we really
learn it's not it's not healthy because
someone goes from feeling amazing in
what they're doing and thriving to
actually find it yeah so let's talk a
bit about let's talk a bit about the
last couple years before sort of the
whole coronavirus piece right so yeah so
obviously you're talking about so
execute your free year business plan
that yeah add from the get-go right yeah
profitable busy yes healthy sighs why so
then the net so then you then decided it
was a five-year vision that we're gonna
create for the board right so obviously
got your brother in that had to ruin
Pat's and FD and looks at financial
models these sorts of things so why why
did you choose to what actually wait
sorry let's just frame up where you were
before the coronavirus PSO like where
where where are you like today and then
we'll sort of dig into it yes so so
before the chronovisor piece we've got
headcount - I think it was 67 I commonly
see seven people give or take offices in
London we lost a Manchester office last
year as well which was which has been
really great and we and and our
international business has started to
grow we actually started that in 2016
but it's um
it started out as one person JJ and
they've kind of grown now into kind of
replicating the core parts of the UK
business in Europe and North America and
that's in their areas that will expand a
lot so so that's where we were more
about revenue ones last year net fees
were about six million okay and we we
were on track this year for net fees to
be about 7.3 million so we were students
has been steady growth again absolutely
a really steady growth and I think I
would say the last two that back 2016 to
the first year
the five-year strike first yeah it was a
good year but it was a bit of like a
high fiving year from the back it now
like we've really ramped the headcount
and we thought this is amazing yeah but
we probably love this yeah we know we
still we still at profitability didn't
grow 2016 absolutely it hasn't revenues
grown but profit abilities remained
fairly steady a level we're very
comfortable across the last three years
because we've always just that we're
investing in the business so much and
people people's salaries got but going
on so yeah what was really good I think
those three days have been the hardest
and the best we really had to work out
how to build a leadership team and
management team and how to and how to
make sphere an amazing experience for
everyone in the company but when the
company had changed through growth so if
someone joins fear as a graduate now we
wanted to be a phenomenal experience the
way that it was when we had our very
first graduate but it's a different
experience different has been yeah but
actually I think what I hope is we've
got that into amazing shape and I think
the hiring over the last two years the
last 18 months in particular has been
the best it's ever been we've got an
amazing bar for the talent dawning
sphere now every level telling our
hirings that the best it's ever been and
the quality and the depth in the team is
just phenomenal and over the last 18
months not not overnight but a lot of
things really came together just a
contribution from from the whole
business has just been it's just really
seismic yeah absolutely brilliant what
what that meant was we've kind of got
this point where we we got to the size
we are but we can really see the next
bit of the business for next round of
growth actually looked look look look
look pretty easy six weeks ago so why
why did you get your people involved so
much in the five-year vision and how
much of an impact is at hand I think
that listening is the premise for making
good decisions you've got you've got
you've got a listen before you act so as
we got bigger we knew we had lots of
great ideas in a company and we wanted
to listen to them and hear them so we
just we wanted to harvest people's views
on things to help us make decisions
together and to help us make better
decisions and and people at different
levels and have been in the company for
different length of time have a
different view and I'm always really
open to to everyone's views so so yes so
we wanted to kind of engage people
involve people and hear their thoughts
on things yeah okay yeah maybe and then
nothing after is it fair to say that do
you think Matt's also played its part in
Y been out to keep people yes I'm sure
I'm sure does you have been having a
voice of having a role to play we know
we do surveys in them you know having a
voice is it's very very very important
yeah yeah understandably so so okay cool
so and before we sort of segue into
today and how you've been adapting than
these types of things like we've spoken
a lot about hiring you've spoken a lot
about sort of having the right people
strategy making sure people engaging
their job and they're they know how to
progress their career spoken about and
obviously your brother FD like what what
are the other things you think that you
guys invested in or they at the
decisions that you've made do you think
of really impacted or and have enabled
you to get to where your word you're not
I mean so he spoke a lot about hiring
the other thing yeah there's a few
six-month I'm just being brave and being
willing to make decisions so I remember
off that in 2017 mum had grown a lot
we had a contract we really wanted to
expand but we didn't have a great plan
for it international was the same we'd
got to point out sure we had we said to
all the managers you can have contracts
and international people in your in your
business units okay but we had this
strat day it was the first one we had
actually with the management team
off-site with the board and the
management team and and actually after
that it was a great day and then after
it Lawrence just said to me can we meet
for a beer intimate Wales where we both
live and a few days later I met him he
said the structure is not right is not
know
while internet international you said
international needs to be a standalone
business you know and contract needs to
be establish unit and we always spoke
about focus no but lots of companies
talk about an eight inch wide the market
focus and he said what you what we're
doing right now it's it's at least these
these things aren't gonna grow they're
just gonna be after thoughts so we got
together and I spoke to Niall and we
said look we've just we've just got a
mix a few things up a bit
sonar at that point we said would take
international on and that meant taking
some people away from other managers and
jemmye we said would take contract on
which meant again taking some people
away from other managers and so we we've
always been okay with making decisions
that might be uncomfortable that people
might not necessarily get in the first
instance but if we know they'll make a
really big difference in the long run
and we're prepared to make them if it's
right for the business yeah because
because in good faith we know that it's
going to really benefit people so we've
been really prepared to make both small
decisions that that make a really big
difference when it comes to scalability
and and we're very fortunate that we've
got a group of people that understand
that and get on board with it quickly
okay and yes we've been really willing
to make decisions and to back-back
people and back ideas so I think that I
think from from what I'm understanding
getting and I think a huge part as to
how you've got to where you've got to is
this layer of management and I think
I've heard it loads of networking events
will creat networking events on that
that can be the most challenging part
for business owners and it's a key part
to scale them right so obviously I know
you sort of really approach this early
on but you've also learned a lot now you
nearly eight years in the journey but
for those listening that are finding it
hot they'd find it hard to find like
they're finding it hard to see their
leaders in their four walls or not
knowing how to give people an
opportunity to prove that their leader
whatever like what what are the the key
learnings they're on yeah like maybe
give people time if they really give
people time if someone moves
a management job I think it takes in the
first year just to find their feet I
really do and to understand what the job
is I think with any new job and we will
say people should be moving into new
jobs internally every few years I think
when you in a new job first of all you
don't understand what the job is then
you usually get a rude awakening when
you realize you're doing it you're
probably not doing as well as you can
and then it takes you six to twelve
months to master it I remember a bit of
feedback my manager gave me lately he'll
Claire she was amazing I've been in my
management job about four or five months
and she said to me do you like doing
your management job ed and I said yeah I
love it so I was interesting I wondered
when you're actually gonna start doing
it what would you means is that well you
know you're at your desk or on your
phone or every day and that's brilliant
but there's a few people around you who
you're supposed to be helping and I
would she's like just just you just you
just don't give them enough time it and
I was all right and I so thought I don't
want to get very much time because I
wanna crack on and build so I and I
think Waits and when people go into when
people go into job of managing people I
think it takes at least a year for them
to housing how do you transition them so
is it straight say AB train training
first and then one person's take on
shadow them work with them obviously use
progress a career development plan and
just so much support the support is the
absolute key so where you're
transitioning and it is new is this have
you got a dedicated you used to be me
and now what really changed for us is
we've just got an amazing senior
management team who bringing through
amazing managers who bring in through
amazing people I followed somewhat Holly
who's one of our one of our managers she
joined us as a graduate and and yeah you
know for first year you've being a
recruitment consultant she didn't think
she could do the job and then first year
being a team leader she didn't think she
could do the job and then she takes
she's no she's taking on so many
different challenges over the last four
years and she just knocks every single
one of them out of the park and I'm okay
and and that's around about the people
she's got around her but but I remember
there were so many times when she tried
to resign and from the company and or
being a manager because she didn't think
she could do it so just just loads of
support and don't believe a loads of
support and loads of belief in people
and
go to training and and time I think
everyone rushes to make decision so
quickly I look how long I know I know
obviously everyone's different the light
if I'm there sort of consulting that's
billing well and you see an opportunity
in me and building the team around me
whatever what what's the typical time
frame you've like with your experience
is like right he should move here now
but in two years time I went to be
behind the team of X or I don't know
what's the yeah ask you a question it's
really efficient actually I would it's a
first of all its management right for
someone because you've got be really
ready to actually want to want to invest
your time and others and you have gotten
so you have an option for both by the
way so it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely yeah and people all the great
diversity of people move into management
jobs and out of management jobs and know
like open manager to Pranab sink I think
that's one of the real problems with
recruitment actually where people think
you've got to be managed yeah you hear
about it terrible because actually
recruitments an amazing industry and
there's an argument say like you could
never ever ever have to worry about
anybody else keep back
bill 300 grand they stay in a market
develop your Billings to a massive level
get out see clients and do this amazing
phenomenal job make loads of money have
loads of flexibility and and that's a
really great job I feel like there's a
bit as a pressure sometimes to be to be
a manager just because it looks like
it's the right thing to do yeah the best
career decisions are always just doing
what what suits you what you most want
to do I think it takes a lot of
confidence actually to say I really I
really want to be a phenomenal recruiter
and and that's my path but but we really
encourage that similarly people on the
manage we really encourage that too if
if they really want to do the right
reasons and they're willing to willing
to go through the hard yards because it
is a proper emotional rollercoaster I
think stands a bit building manager job
you got to be really up for it so it's a
typical time frame what we're talking
people I think people can step into that
job with anywhere from two years
experience and up but we say you've got
to have build at least 180 K over a
12-month period you know you've got to
be doing that sort of level of revenue
and and see that consistently and then
it's about how you do it so we'd say you
know something nurtures key customers
know just can that relationships we're
so like is it is in line with our our
policies and then when you move into
that management job
I think that within within two years of
being in that job you you could be
running you know teams of teams of three
or four people and hopefully ready to
take on a new challenge but that's
inheriting a team or launching another
area a bit developing your managers
beneath you okay Edie what what has been
the biggest challenges mate cuz yeah
it's like do you not I mean I think
people listen though I this all sounds
great it's all gone to plan why what
what have been the biggest challenges
for you grown and run this business
always people issues yeah always people
issues the biggest challenge is managing
growth it's managing keeping lots of
people happy that's really hard I found
that yeah I found that personally very
hard because I you know I really am
naturally someone who wants to make
people happy and I want to do the right
thing and so when that doesn't happen
you tell that person absolutely yeah I
do I've got better and not taking that
personally but that definite ik time and
it's just a sense like the realization
that you simply can't keep X amount of
people who have different views happy
because one thing that someone like
someone else doesn't say yeah so I found
it hard to get much more like this is
the policy and we're sticking to it
because as you get bigger you have to be
a bit more like that
losing key people we've lost key people
along the way that's what that's of real
blow really tough yep and yeah it's it's
difficult every single day and it's
difficult every week and it's difficult
every month and it's difficult every
year but what we're really good at as a
business is is is is not getting
distracted by what's difficult and
what's hard and just just just we've
been really good at keeping their sense
of moving forward going and I'm good
actually only really assessing things
now I usually say at the end of the year
obviously current situation to be
different but yeah we kind of know start
the year we saying we say but we want to
be at the end of the year with key goals
you know around people around revenue
and then I give it the year to see to
see where we've got to obviously
checking in along the way I go I always
go back each each month and read my
goals in the beginning of the year
because sometimes I think it's not going
very well and I can look at my goals and
I'm like I know actually we're on track
like stop stop freaking out yeah yeah
it's difficult everyday but I think
we've got good good good perseverance
and it's made easier by by the people
that you know we
we've got there's always someone who
picks you up now you know I go into
office um I'll be feeling like everyone
knows a certain way and say hello in the
morning you always we always met by
cheery faces and that helps a lot so
before we talk about coronavirus I just
want to take this opportunity to just
decide one quick question which is
obviously a lot of recruiters listen to
this so I guess in in your time and just
think about sphere and and sort of your
best people would have been the sort of
real common traits that using and your
best people do you think that it'll
really make up a typical great recruiter
in your eyes over the last year couple
years hungry and hardworking there's no
substitute for hard work I don't think
there ever will be
so you're hungry and hardworking and
ambitious what cliches and and able to
able to bounce back quickly because
that's always going to be there but it's
better you respond to them and we don't
chase a quick buck I think people who
are good at playing the long game so no
sticking out a market going back and
work
I think the traitor I think stop people
doing whereas up working a job sending
out one short listen and thinking I've
covered that I'm off yeah
yes I think people actually expect it
expect and plan for the worst you
quickly yeah yeah I think it was
different people successful in different
ways and we're really kind of we're
really accepting off of that yeah if I
was summarizing ambition hardwork and
and and and hunger there's no substitute
that's our gesture to be the best I
think it does okay and and sticking at
it you know if you want if you want to
be great something you're willing to
stick at it you'll you'll get there one
way or another okay so let let's talk
about the last couple of weeks and
what's bigger than your world mate what
what what what's happened it's been
really stressful it's been really hard
it feels much less stressful now and
much less hard now it was just the pace
of change wasn't it was how quickly is
how quickly it happened
we've kind of seen it developing in
February and early March so we we had an
idea that the market was going to get
gonna get worse we had started to
project a week before went to lockdown
we thought this this could hit you know
revenue by 50% for a few months the
reality is it's hit much harder than
that and it's gonna hit harder than that
for longer but what you think and I know
no one knows but what was watch FD
planning we've been planning to run at
about 75% down fall until what end of
the year no not as bad as that no we
subscribe send down we're about six
percent down in April yeah we had a
great q1 really amazing you ever did
have a good great Q on a gun thank [ __ ]
for that we had a great key warm okay
and then yeah we'll be sixty percent
down in April and then we're planning to
be 75 percent down May June and July
yeah and it's pretty hard to project
much beyond yeah yeah sure okay so
that's what that's what you're preparing
for that's what we're preparing for and
then we're preparing for no worst-case
scenarios thereafter the
government-backed furlough schemes been
really helpful yeah utilize that we have
year and I hope you in a human way and
in the best way the most engaging way
possible week sort made it voluntary
initially and then we have started to
put people on furlough just where
there's no where the market is is the
thing with the thing with furlough is it
needs to be timed well you actually need
to be very decisive with it because
there's no point of um of waiting for a
month because with every passing week we
are getting better we are getting closer
to the end it might not feel like it but
the end is Troy you'll you wouldn't you
need some time when you can get all the
people like people back needs further
yeah we could be a granese we need to
furlough people need what most wouldn't
cut down what most companies are dying
said whilst furloughs here use it now
because now is the time to use it you
know because when it ends you what
everyone wants to bring everyone back
into the business so furlough is a great
way to cut costs which enable you to
bring everyone back into the business
you know the for that
no for the ride back up again is that it
has that been the main government scheme
that you utilized all of you were sort
of yeah we looked at alone which we've
applied for we as how's that process
yeah that's great yeah bank with a net
West they've got 65 recruitment
companies and and and we ranked in the
top five of their portfolio probably
number one I didn't say that but
probably they're very keen to support us
but of course no you could take a loan
which is great you still got to pay it
back yeah so so that they and we okay
loan and then furloughs furnish anything
that brings money back into the business
cystogram everyone's come on of you have
you obviously an experienced that yet so
so you cannot be you can apply in our
client you know yeah yes we were
probably haven't the money hasn't come
through yet but it will
and always the process is it okay I
think you had a terrible day doing it
but is the reason why is because I think
it's so easy to see these people talk
about on telly and it sounds great but
people need to know the actual realities
of getting their hands on them all right
yes get your hands on the loan money is
really so yeah get your hand alone
money's really hard and the banks were
only loan you that money if you've been
a great business precoded and if they
believe you and if they believe you mean
compared yes so companies that haven't
been performing and not only get loans
you have to be unbelievably organized
with your finances and have a very
robust business yeah so so yes that load
the loans are tough to get but we will
get one the and then furlough furlough
is difficult for companies with bad cash
flow because you've got to pay your
employees and claim the money back yeah
a lot so you've got a player at first
and then and then clicked and some
people if you've got to furlough 20
people and that cost you 100,000 pounds
of salaries and you're only gonna get X
amount back and you've got to wait for
weeks to get it there's lots of em as a
model so if you have 100k to pay so that
makes that difficult and okay and and
then and then everything else you do to
keep mine in your business their
deferral so you can defer the eighty but
you've still got to pay so so but yeah
it will be spicy what was what's been
the most difficult decision you had to
make so far I don't I think I don't I
don't think we've had I don't think
we've had difficult decisions because I
respond my responsibility is to make
good decisions for the company if we
don't make good decisions for the
company we're fundamentally not doing
our jobs so we've had we've had to take
tough decisions when when we went into
lockdown we let we let we let 12 people
go prefect respectively furlough them
and that was a tough decision because it
wasn't a decision that we wanted to take
and they were you know largely people
who would have gone on to be successful
in sphere but it's it's also very easy
decision because when you're looking in
the numbers and you know we knew how bad
I think that we cannot say on this might
blow over but our strong views aboard
was this isn't gonna blow and blow there
this is not gonna be just something that
you know the importance of making it
yeah yeah you've got to make them early
you've got to be brave and and and and
and in my views and I'm really people
responsibility I think is it is
irresponsible if you're running a
company to not make decisions to enable
the company to move forward and thrive
in typically you're putting too much at
risk for too many people so they're
tough decisions but not ones that you
know you don't you don't wake up in the
morning think oh I want to let 12 people
go today it's horrible you know it's
this doubloon you know it's really
really horrible okay but but but but but
if you know that the right decisions to
take then you know you take them every
day so I don't I don't find those
decisions but they're hard decisions to
make and they're they're not they're not
fun decisions to make but I will never
shy away from taking them because we've
got we've got too many people click ask
them we've got a great business to keep
moving forward with so that you've been
in the going for a while how do you how
do you see sort of obviously no one
knows but how what do you think the
opportunities are going to be over the
next couple of months and how do you see
things turning out from a sort of
recruitment business owner perspective
yeah next few months are better there's
two things one you just have to control
your costs everywhere everything really
on a bore not be read on bortronian cost
share you've you've got to do that and
not just next two months but for the
following ones because the next two
months for most good companies won't be
a problem it the problem comes if you
haven't got enough money in the business
to to to to still operate in a tough
mark
it yeah because if you haven't got
enough finding your business to offer in
a tough market you're gonna have to make
really deep cut back so you know we
won't do that we don't want to do that
so yeah the next once you just go really
control your cost so you're ready for
the rebound and so that's about that's
the cost control there's amazing work
that we can all do right now we're
developing incredible relationships of
clients incredible relationship with
candidates and we are making placements
and we're nurturing existing
relationships and we're winning new ones
and we found we found a few things as a
business that we think we can get much
better at I won't go to a d3x is boring
it's exciting for us but but yes so
we've got to make you've got to make
work meaningful you know we've got to be
the same business the way we work
together the values we work to the way
we deal with one another with the way we
deal with our clients you've got to just
know be exact the same in terms of your
values but you've got to adapt really
quickly to the market so so yeah next
few months are identified the rules the
game play the game as well as you
possibly can in terms of the actions
you're taking and how you're engaging
people and working with people and then
as things pick back up again I think
it's about really getting the vision in
place of people you know where you are
and how are you gonna go forwards and
then once you've got the vision in place
and hopefully back in the office people
back from furlough that's the time to
really say right here's where we are
here's what we want to achieve here's
how we want to achieve it and then you
go out there and you do it again yeah
but you've got you but the answers to
those questions the realities that
they're revealing themselves month by
month really come on so holding on on
the virus however before you just one
and two last questions mate how have you
found how have you found and have you
been motivating your team remotely
because that's comment quite a lot and
people finding that difficult I think is
really hard
we like the usual things that get
quizzes bingo cook alongs with people
cocktail making yeah
keep as much normality as possible one
two ones at the same time
company meetings at the same time I've
been doing darlings two or three times a
week doing training sessions or just my
own age where people can ask me
questions so lots of communicating over
communicating yeah yeah yes and no I
think at the beginning I was sending out
an email every morning and I thought
that was probably
a bit too much all right now things or
just the same [ __ ] which are no people
fundamental thought off so you know if
every week we're looking at what we can
do giving it back to the business
sharing ideas getting involved with
everyone
we've getting the goals right so
expectations need to be clear making
work meaningful in terms like what we
actually asking people to do how we
doing
I think simplifying everything like
really simple really simple tasks we can
do together and it's hard because what
everyone really wants to know is is this
gonna be okay yeah and what what what I
wish I could say is exactly how because
that's what people really want they know
when's its gonna stop when am i back
from furlough what's what's the company
gonna do we we know we know that we will
be more than okay we know we're going to
come through this we know that when we
were fret back on this it's gonna be
another part of the making in the
business it's just you can't give people
for how that everyone wants right now
because I would be lying if I said I
know the day we can do this or the day
that the markets gonna turn to 50% 75% a
hundred of what we used to but but but
but what we do know is that we'll
navigate it well and get through it and
come out and come out and great you know
and get back to being in great shape but
yes some things you just can't answer in
the way that you want to so that's the
hub that's the bit that I find hardest
you want to give people the answers but
but but you just can't okay so before I
actually the last question and just sort
of with all your experience now that
you've sort of got under you about I
guess knowing what you know now what
what would you be saying to yourself or
others that might be sort of early on in
their recruitment business journey like
ya know well you know now what would you
be saying to yourself early on do you
think just stress out this really yeah
just focus on doing the right things no
be okay yeah yeah just have a plan and
stick to it and nothing's ever as bad as
it seems
it really isn't like it's never as good
as it seems it's never as bad as it
seems it's all just don't the next it's
the heir perspective
next thing in the next they live yeah it
works out in the end it really does nice
look before I see last question what I
always say to people what they're
excited about but seems a bit weird
asking that with all this [ __ ] going on
well this business being over
I actually know I actually know the
answer
hm I'm getting sighs throughout the day
when I'm in an office with everyone
that's fear first of all hanging out at
them and talk to them and see how they
are and then secondly standing up and
saying right this is what we're doing if
they're we going this is how we're gonna
yeah this is what we're doing this new
mogan engine that's gonna be an
incredible moment and yeah just just
getting on minutes to that that's so the
last question before I let you go what
if you could communicate to every single
recruiter out there business owner
they'd listen to Ed's advice they take
on your advice they implement it
tomorrow it could be a phrase or
sentence of words what what would you
say to the people if they're all
listening what do you say to them
identify a back of a [ __ ] packet what you
want to do and by when make sure that
it's your truth so yet you want to do X
bi bi Y and jot down the things you
think you need to do to do it and then
stick to those things and be okay with
it not always going to plan but just
keep coming back to the to the steps
that you you know how many first of the
land have a plan and stick to it yeah
then you've definitely a man of a plan
yes ed it's been a pleasure really
appreciate your time thanks a lot all
right Cheers hm